livres disques tee shirts badges encore
un disque casquette bande dessinée
batman se décline sous toutes les formes
il doit être possible de s'habiller de
manger de rêver entièrement batman
d'être obsédé par le logo jaune et noir
en forme de chauve souris ou d'amygdales
au choix je me suis laissé dire que on
vous à cambrioler juste pour vous voulez
ce genre de choses oui tu t'es celle
d'un vous voyez derrière moi une niche
qui a été copieusement aménagé vu tous
les produits que nous avions elle a été
elle a été quasiment venait en moins de
huit jours et les questions extérieures
du bâtiment ont été aussi cambriolé en
une nuit on a même eu droit à un
commando champagne au suicide mais qui
rentrait dans le cinéma il y avait une
grande silhouette de deux mètres de
batman 8 2 m de haut ils ont rentré il y
en a deux qui ont ouvert les portes les
deux autres ont pris ont pris la
silhouette et sont partis en courant les
a jamais rattrapé